hello everyone we mentioned we're going
to cover one more game from the tata
steel chess tournament but i decided not
to show another game from the masters
division rather we were gonna show one
game from the challengers division as
the winner of the challengers division
as you all know gets to play in next
year's masters edition so here we have a
game between Belarus Grandmaster
Vladislav Kavala he's playing against
international master from netherlands
stefan clippers and it's not sure how to
pronounce Dutch names but could be could
be Coopers it's a really interesting
game and well as usual I don't know if
your if you're into let's say League of
Legends or maybe into hard stone or
something like that you know that well
the better you get
you will then face of course stronger
opponents and when you constantly face
wrong your opponents like if you're I
don't know in in Challenger or in
hearthstone if you are in legend you
will most likely will have something
that is called a meta so such is also in
chess there are also there are metal
openings and since this is not the
highest tier tournament like Tata Steel
masters this is that a still challengers
here you will encounter some of meta
openings so to say they are still all
very correct and very well correct is
the correct term I would say I'm not
sure how to put it you will not see like
gambits or only half correct gambits or
incorrect gambits but you will see
something that you will not be seeing
like in 20 750 or 2800 tournaments so
without further ado let's check out this
very nice game so we have e 4 by kovalev
and we have e 6 the French defense d 4
we have D 5 sorry about that
nice the D to the tarush variation of
the French and now C 5 we have 90 G 2 F
3 C capture Sun d4 Knight captures and
now nice to see 6 Bishop to b5
developing and also pinning the knight
on c6 Bishop to d7 and now
Knight captures we have bee captures on
c6 and now Bishop go back to d3 and as
you can see here white is somewhat
leading in development but black also
has something to show for he has a very
nice semi open B file for the rook black
has an excellent center and should not
have any problems
you know development wise Queen to c7
developing the Queen also the Queen will
come in handy in supporting of the C for
advancement and also you are already
attacking the King site should White
Castle kingside we have Queen to e2 by
White Knight to e7 and now comes castles
Knight to g6 a nice square for the
knight also as you don't have any
support you can't kick it away just yet
Knight goes to f3 and now Bishop to d6
pressuring the H do pawn if the knight
would ever move we have rook to e1 and
now Knight to f4 and interestingly this
has all been played before bunch of
characters Bishop captures for example
in 1976 in Moscow as a car of Alexander
played this position with the white
pieces against Tigran Petrosian and c4
was used in that game where ihara was
able to draw a game against Tigran
Petrosian but in this game Kovalev uses
g3 it's a new move in this position and
as of this moment and move 14 we have a
completely new game mushroom goes back
to these six and now he captures on d5
if I was also possible forcing the
bishop to move back but as the black
king is still in the center it does make
sense to open up or to open lines C
captures on d5 of course the pawn is
pinned and now comes Luke 8 2 c1 white
wants to push c4 and bust open at the
center and also open up at the C file
for his rook rook to d8 black is still
waiting to see what happens before
committing the castling we have c4 by
white D captures on c4 and now rook
captures and c4 attacking the Queen
Queen to b6
and now comes Knight to e5 and here
indeed it would be castling would come
prematurely here for example if you
actually decided to castle here then
capture some h7 would win you the game
immediately after keen captures queen h5
check King moves now come through here
and there is very little you can do
about this checkmate even if sex will
not help you as the knight is covering
the f7 square so you cannot escape with
the king
so after this Knight to e5 move with
Bishop captures eliminating the night
Queen captures and only now does black
castle as the Queen now the Knight has
been eliminated so the f7 square is not
protected so here you could capture but
black would just still be able to escape
Queen h5 we go with the same variation
row gauge for but now f6 makes room for
the King and you are no longer able to
improve your position in any way that
would help you continue this attack and
any checking or whatnot would simply
result in black escaping
quick if I check you can go to e7 and
here black would be very safe so here
after castles we have a three and the
queen is still guarding the b2 pawn so
perhaps b4 is also planned and here we
have looked to see it
Stefan offers a trade of rooks we have
looked the d4 and here it's very
interesting as we already mentioned this
sacrifice doesn't work but we have
worked to d4 now and the bishop is now
under attack so what would you do here
it's it's an interesting position for
you to pause and you're really or
spidey-sense should really start tingle
at the tingle here as here in the game
Bishop to c6 was played which is a
terrible mistake but it's also well it's
it's an it's a very easy one to make
for example if you go Queen the c7 here
guard the bishop and offer a trade of
Queens you'll be fine if you go Bishop
to e8 you'll be fine but rush up to c6
this doesn't work and it doesn't work
for a very specific reason after black
plays Bishop to c6 feel free to pause
the video here and try to find what
vladislav played here in this position
that really gives white a crushing a
combination
well it's I mean it's pretty obvious but
still for those of you who were able to
do it as it is a Monday congratulations
you are in
excellent attacker and for those of you
who just won't enjoy it show worship
captures on h7 and now it works and now
you might think okay but how does it
work now
well King captures on h7 was played and
here rook to g4 and it was in this
position that Dutch international master
Stephan Cooper's resigned at the game as
there is nothing you can do to defend
checkmate but well we're gonna return to
this first we have to see here in this
position after instead of rook to d4 why
doesn't it work now here Bishop captures
doesn't work with the same idea came
here and rubgy for because the bishop is
protecting the e6 pawn that's that's the
point the Queen also protects d6 pawn
and here if black for example played f6
you could go rook to h4 check King g8
and now if you go Queen h5 black can
always escape and there's no way to
continue the attack but here now you
will understand the problem after rook
c8 rogue d4 and better to c6 y brush-up
to c6 is such a terrible problem because
the bishop is no longer protecting the
e6 pawn as it's no longer on d7 and also
it blocks the Queen's protection of the
pawn so this is why the sacrifice now
works Bishop captures King captures and
now rook to g4 and now there's no way to
defend because after all the lines for
example if g6 then wreckage for check
King g8 and the rocket shade this will
be checkmate but and of course if rock
here defending the pond and Queen a5 is
checkmate but the real beauty is that
after f6 now you have this option of
playing rook h4 check and if King g6
Queen h5 is checkmate and now if King g8
now the bishop no longer protects the e6
pawn so now Queen captures on e6 is them
you can go anywhere along the edge file
the rook is covering that you have to
block with the rook and now this rook is
unguarded that is the point
not only is the bishop to not
controlling these six pawn but also it's
not guarding the rook Queen captures
which check you have to block and now
everything falls apart 26 check rook f7
Queen h3 can't
do much to protect check make sure you
have to move the rook but still you're
just gonna get work h8 checking of seven
Queen h5 check block and queen h7
checkmate the rookin e1 is controlling
the entire efile as well so a very easy
sacrifice to miss but what a beautiful
move this Bishop to see six blocks the
Queen's the protection of d6 pawn the
bishop no longer protects just and the
bishop no longer regards the rook and
here everything simply is possible Sam
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and also I did prepare the standings of
the challengers section as you can see a
lot is lava
Kovalev won the Challenger section of
the Titus till 2019 with 10 out of 13 so
that's one and a half point ahead of
unrest banker bedroom englidh Ora and
Maximus you guys who are all three of
them are tied for second place so that's
quite an achievement a point and half
ahead of everyone else then Anton gorev
and there Ben allow me with seven and a
half out of 13 then with seven we have
Afghani brave and Potomac Zulu then with
six Lukas one forest Vincent came our
wood five and a half out of 13 then
rameshwar amanda with 5 out of 13 then
Daenerys a two cassava and Elizabeth
fights with three and a half out of 13
and then Stefan cooper's who lost this
game that you've just seen with 3 out of
13 so as it always goes the winner of
the Challenger section plays in the
master section next year so Stefan could
not stay for Cooper's but Vladislav
kovalev Grandmaster from Belarus will be
playing in the 2020 edition of the Tata
Steel masters and so far only Magnus
Carlsen and the vladislav are surely
playing in the next year status 2
masters and also as we didn't show the
standings after the Masters edition
there we have it Magnus Carlsen 9 out of
13 then in second place onigiri with 8
and half out of 13 the only game giver
lost is that the young
from Nia she in the pony she too when he
blundered a piece in Hin the first
gameplay played then in third place
nipple also with seven and a half out of
13 and then ding Liron with seven and a
half out of 13 and I believe ding leerin
the only player alongside magnus carlsen
who hasn't lost a single game that the
Dingley reign is simply unbeatable he
even finished the candidates who without
losing a single game also each wanna
turn on and on seven and a half out of
13 videos right on seven out of 13 then
timur a job of and samuel Shanklin and
richard report and six and a half out of
13 young shift of Duda five and a half
out of 13 volume instead of save and
share my madero 5 out of 13 and the
Jordan van forest and Vollmer kramnik on
four and a half out of 13 so definitely
not the greatest tournament for Vladimir
Kramnik
or Shah here mummy they are off special
moment Yara of who I believe has not won
a single game yet in 2019 and every game
he played in the Tata Steel masters lost
him
some rating points as he saw high rated
I believe he was 27 and something points
in this tournament which is huge
I mean that's that's incredible I don't
I don't think he is in the 2800 club no
longer but any longer but you know he's
a great player I'm sure he'll get back
there but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you enjoyed the
coverage I would like to thank
Constantine power love is at Hanbali Dan
O'Hanlon Jeffrey Miller and inform ed or
informed for a contribution to my
channel thank you lotsa really
appreciate it
it was really a pleasure of meeting Dan
O'Hanlon we met in the in London during
the World Chess Championship match
between Carson Caruana is really a
lovely gentleman yeah like I said as
usual you can check to my previous video
so your thing called for watching and
I'll see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content continuing the
Capablanca saga and if you know of any
excellent games in the Gibraltar chess
festival haven't really been following
that do use hash tag suggestion and I
will
check up on your suggestions so thank
you all and I will see you soon
[Music]